a newspaper was about to be thrown away
by my next-door neighbor who was
convicted of multiple rapes and on the
front section of the tech section
was about Sir Alec Jeffries and he had
taken the blood samples of men from
Lester and identified Colin Pitchfork as
the murderer of a woman in
leicestershire for the first time in
history science was used to identify
someone genetically
when I read that newspaper I knew one
thing I was innocent and I could prove
it
hello and welcome to this episode of
extraordinary lives the podcast from
that Bible I'm Ben Paul Jones and
joining us in the studio today is Nick
Yaris Nick great to have you here thank
you Ben
um Nick for anyone who doesn't know who
you are could you give us a brief
introduction to yourself
yes sir I'm from Philadelphia
Pennsylvania and at the age of 20 I was
sentenced to die for the rape and murder
of a woman I never met in my life I then
went on to spend the next 23 years of my
life in solitary confinement on death
row awaiting to be executed
thankfully DNA testing proved me
innocent in 2003 and I was released in
from custody in 2004.
amazing amazing introduction and um I'm
really excited to hear all about your
story but let's go back to the beginning
you know who are you as a kid how did
you grow up
I grew up in the city of Philadelphia
Pennsylvania on the east coast of the
United States
but unfortunately for me at the age of
seven I had a traumatic experience where
I was attacked by a man in my
neighborhood and I was assaulted with a
Fieldstone and he left me with brain
damage for what reason
I don't know I I think it was just a
sexual predator move that the man wanted
to attack me and then his frustration or
fear he hit me in the head with a
Fieldstone
I was hit in the frontal lobe of my head
and it caused Aphasia and it also
restricted my optic nerves so I had to
wear corrective lenses on my eyes
I didn't know about Aphasia and Aphasia
can be identified as simply as someone
who stutters because their brain is
working too fast for their vernacular
system to catch up and speak
mine was different in that every time
that I got stressed out I would become
monocited and only be able to see out of
my right eye and I wouldn't be able to
function in an argument I kept shutting
down in frustration and so I had a lot
of outburst and and anger as a child so
you said this was the beginning of you
going off the rails so to speak so what
happened there what was the progression
of that I kept trying to evade the fear
so initially I began drinking alcohol
and it was one of those things where the
first time I got intoxicated on alcohol
and no longer felt afraid I wasn't
afraid of that being seen by my attacker
in the neighborhood or being in an alley
alone and have him terrorize me again
and again
and I think that feeling of wanting to
not be afraid is what drove me to become
an alcoholic and then a drug addict so
it was you were using them as an escape
basically yeah a numbing sensation an
escape
fear alleviator those are the real
reasons a lot of people will start
drinking and doing drugs because they're
filled with the fear or they're filled
with anger and they want to be done with
it and the easiest way to a lot of young
people will find is through
intoxications
um
and what age was this that this was
because you said that um did you say at
the age of seven you were hit with this
Stone yeah so about the age of 10 11 and
12 I started drinking wow by the time I
was 14 I was fully intervolved with
drugs
um by the time I was 17 years old I was
injecting methamphetamine into my veins
wow and did you have a safety net like a
family around you or friends or anything
like that or did you removed yourself
from them
I was so chaotically violent no one
could care about me
I literally hated myself and at the age
of 17 or 18 I had no qualms about being
violent disrespectful I hated myself why
would I care about anyone or what they
would say to me
and am I right in thinking that you
began to have problems with the law
runings with the law
exactly what happens when most people
were addicted to narcotics or alcohol I
ran a fellow of the police because I
became a petty Thief to try and keep up
with my addictions and unfortunately
this is what unraveled my life I was a
car thief in the Philadelphia area on
December 4th 1981 at the age of 20
I stole an automobile and I got chased
by the Philadelphia police and they gave
me a terrible beating
about three weeks after that
I started using drugs again
really badly
and I went out one night in a stolen car
again and I got stopped in the city of
Chester Pennsylvania the police officer
who pulled me over this time didn't have
to chase me because I was terrified of
running I had just received a beating
for doing that
the officer got angry at me because I
wouldn't get out of my car and he pulled
me out of the car and began fighting
with me I knocked the club away from him
after pushing his hands away from my
throat and he pulled his gun out when he
did I put both hands on the gun and
unfortunately it went off at that time
oh my God where was it pointed when it
went down at the ground right that must
have been terrifying well it really
escalated from there because I started
to shout okay repeatedly as if that was
my surrender
he put the gun under my chin put me in
the backseat of the automobile and then
composed himself for at least a minute
while he thought about what he was going
to do next he grabbed the radio from the
car's Dash and very pointedly pretended
like the attack was still going on by
shouting excitedly uh officer assist
police officer assist
shots fired help help help help my God
so all of the ensuing officers that came
to the scene thought he was under attack
they drugged me out of the car they beat
me they put me in the Paddy Wagon it's
called and they took me to jail and
charged me with the attempted murder and
kidnapping of a police officer why do
you think he did that he was angry at me
see
the officer Benjamin Wright who would
later be arrested for being a criminal
himself had never failed to overpower
somebody in his life for the first time
ever I overpowered them by resisting him
and I think that really struck his ego
so he said to the ensuing officers who
arrived I took his gun off him that I
actually jumped out of my car ran back
to him took his gun off him and was
trying to blow his brains out with his
own gun when he heroically overpowered
me and took the gun back so he literally
flipped the story of what happened on
the spot yeah wow I was so devastated by
this lie
as I stood next to my public defender he
told me I was going to spend the rest of
my life in jail
did you try to explain what happened at
the time when the other police arrived
or did you just you know how what were
you saying when they arrived and he was
starting to say to them he took the gun
off me Etc I didn't I didn't get a
chance to speak they beat me right when
one of your fellow officers has almost
been killed
it's not pleasant in America they were
jacked up at this time with anger
I went into the prison and I capitulated
I fell apart I admit this I did one of
the worst things in my life I laid there
in my own misery going through a drug
withdrawal without any treatment and I
made up a story out of a newspaper that
was in my cell
trying to use a lie to get out of the
lie that was put on me
how would that have helped in America
you can barter your way out of criminal
charges if you know something bigger
than what you've been arrested for right
so you helped them solve a bigger crime
then your charges will be lessened or
thrown out yes right so in my stupid 20
year old drug addict mine I thought I
would play a game on the police hoping
to get released enough so that I could
run away
they told me initially that they were
going to release me on my own
recognizance after they spoke to my
arresting officer and he admitted that
he was going to reduce the charges and I
would be charged with resisting arrest
and be taken to Philadelphia for the
auto theft charges
in other words
initially my Ploy worked because you'd
said that you could you talk us through
that what was the other crime that you'd
said that you knew something about or
you'd help them solve
the only thing in my my cell when I
first was arrested was a newspaper from
Delaware County
on the front page was the mystery of a
missing and then abducted and murdered
woman
who was found in the area and the police
were baffled as to who did this crime I
picked out a friend who one time had
robbed me and and hurt me and I thought
was dead at the time to blame it on
I told the police that this person who I
thought was dead did the crime and told
me about it and hoped that I would be
able to trick the police with this
stupid line
initially they told me they believed me
and they went out and tried to solve the
crime based on my words in this
then they came back to me and they said
the reason I made up a lie about someone
else is I was trying to confess and it
was me who committed this murder and
they wouldn't take no for an answer
wow so you've gone from being the person
who's basically invented it you so you
said you could help them solve the crime
of the mystery of the murder of the lady
they've gone out and then come back and
said actually what you said wasn't true
you must have done it exactly that's a
leap in Logic on their part as well
though yeah but that's because this was
one of those crimes where they needed to
have an assurance to the community of an
arrest right the detective was really
insulted by what I tried to do to him I
kept telling them look you talked to the
officer he said he was going to reduce
my charges surely that's proof that I
didn't try to murder him they said oh
that doesn't matter anymore because you
killed this woman we know you're trying
to come forward that you're blaming it
on a friend that you thought was dead
because you knew we would come back and
find out the truth and we know you want
to tell us tell us why you killed her
and I was like no I didn't do it
so they said you had a breakup with your
girlfriend and they started mocking me
about why she would leave me and I got
angry at them and started shouting at
him and this is how weird it was
they never said that I confessed to
anybody they put a prisoner in the cell
next to me who had been convicted of
robbing the prosecutor's home
he said that I confessed to him after
being in a Cell next to him for one
night
so that was the evidence so he could get
out of his charges they used him
against me and do you think they knew he
was lying
of course they did so they put him in
the cell next to me for one night Ben
but so therefore they so do you think
they that they thought you'd committed
the crime or do you think that they
didn't care who'd committed to Crime I
think that they believed that I
committed the crime okay so they were
doing using any means necessary to solve
the crime and that included a fake
witness yeah wow okay so
I'm now charged with the attempted
murder of a police officer and the rape
and murder of a woman I never met
unfortunately for me the police also
told the local pagans motorcycle gang
that I was in informant
so for the first week of my
incarceration after I was released from
the uh security holding cell
I was attacked every day
I had a man try to put my eye out with a
sharpened broomstick I had urine and
feces thrown in my face and in my cell I
had to stand for hours with my mattress
against my door so that men couldn't
throw things on me
and then when I got the door open for my
shower time I would come out and attack
anybody in front of me whether they did
anything to me or not I was trying to
stop the savagery that was being aimed
at me after a week of that I hung myself
in my soul and a prison guard came in
and cut me down and told me I wasn't
allowed to cheat the state of
Pennsylvania out of my punishment
why was it true that you were in
informant no why would they do that
because they were putting pressure on me
to try and make me come back to them
again to confess
and at that point after a week you
decided enough was enough and and you
wanted out but they wouldn't allow you
to do that
and then I had a visit with my mother in
the hospital in the county jail
in which inmates were making rude
comments about her
and she made me promise no matter what I
went through
never do that
she told me that I was a gift of her
life
and I had no right to destroy that gift
no matter what it was done to me
so literally at the age of 20 I promised
my mother I would never kill myself
wow
so at this point you're in prison and
you know that you've just got to go
through whatever's thrown at you to get
to the sentencing for the crimes that
they're saying you'd committed
ah but the crazy thing is
God had a plan
I was originally taking a trial for the
attempted murder of the police officer
my word against him it should have been
a slam dunk
the jury found me not guilty after 20
minutes of deliberation after hearing
both sides of this story wow
you see the police officer made up this
big story about the attack that I
committed upon him and he used a
photograph of his hand as evidence that
I took the gun off of him
but he told this elaborate story of how
I punched him in his face hit him with
his own pistol breaking his eyeglasses
my lawyer simply said if you were going
to take a photograph of the evidence of
someone assaulting you surely you would
photograph your face in that moment the
jury realized he was lying
so they found me not guilty and it was
one of the worst events because the
prosecutor became so incensed by losing
that trial he threw the case file
against the wall and promised me I would
never leave the county alive he then who
on his own took over the prosecution of
the homicide case of this woman that I
never met and demanded the death penalty
wow
okay and you're 20 at this point 20
years old and you and you've been told
that you're going to be up for the death
penalty how did that feel I was angry
because I saw what they were doing
they weren't going to let me have a fair
trial the next time because they gave me
a fair trial and a jury Found Me Not
Guilty they weren't going to risk this
again I knew that
so in June of 1982 I had just turned 21
years old
a jury was shown a series of photographs
one of which was a photograph of these
two children who were walking in the
snow and they found the victim whose
name was Linda May Craig
the boys kicked the snow away from what
they thought was a mannequin to see if
it was a male mannequin or a female
mannequin only to discover
Mrs Craig was laying there
the children's footprints were black it
was a black and white photograph and
then as they ran away from the figure it
looked like the angel's wings spread out
they showed that jury that photograph
and the jury couldn't look at me again
I knew what was going to happen his
honor told the jury I was only going to
be given a three-day trial
and this was the third day
after they did that and the jury put
their heads down and they couldn't look
at me no more
a boat of lightning struck the
courthouse and knocked all the power out
you can't make this up
I was taken out of the room as if I had
something to do with this moment like I
was trying to an escape or something
they hustled me out of the courtroom
with guns drawn and put me in this big
room on top of the courthouse
there is in that moment I stood there
and I heard God say to me go and look
them in the eye
so
when they got themselves back together
and they took me back in the courtroom
the judge couldn't look at me well he
was about to sentence me to death
I kept asking him how dare you not have
the courage to look me in the eye and
you're about to sentence me to die
aren't you ashamed of that
and when he raised his head he said are
you finished I said no sir you can go to
hell but all they said in the newspaper
was defiant murderer tells judge go to
hell it wasn't the whole story
the jury sentenced me to death
I was placed into custody of Huntington
State Prison the only prison condemned
by the United Nations for its active
practices of torture and I entered a
building in which the average rate of
survival was only five years
five years
and what were the what were the causes
of death in that suicide cancers
mental deterioration so you just lost it
and then
a lot of men just killed each other or
they were killed by staff for themselves
are you aware of this going in there
initially Pennsylvania didn't have a
death row so they put us in the
punishment unit where they broke men
my first two years and myself I wasn't
allowed to speak in my cell
two years he went allowed to just make
any noise
I sung happy birthday to myself on my
22nd birthday and I got a beating for it
four men come into your cell with riot
gear they hold you down while a nurse
who's wearing a riot helmet and a flak
vest has a needle full of Thorazine and
she would run in and stab you in the
buttocks with this needle and then you
would lose the week of your life if you
broke the rules again they dragged you
out of your Zone they put you in a glass
bubble
a brick cell made out of glass bricks
and every 15 minutes they did what was
called a head count and woke you up and
made you stand on your feet and
acknowledge them
for a week
so these were these practices that
you're describing
were they legal or would these be
clusters torture and the guards and the
staff going off the rules
this was actually protocol in the prison
that's why it was condemned by the
United Nations
they literally tortured me like they
tortured everyone else
and was that as soon as you got in there
at 21 years old was that was that your
experience immediately you were putting
a cell and told you're not allowed to
speak anymore
you know what what was the initial
moving in there at such a young age how
did it feel and what did it look like
when I arrived at the prison at the age
of 21
all of the other prisoners were taken
off of the bus and then four men came on
to the uh the bus with riot gear they
always have to hide their faces
they drugged me off the bus and they
lined me up against the wall and then a
lieutenant walked up to me and explained
me the following
you're dead
dead men do not speak in my unit do you
understand me everyone that knew you and
anyone that you loved is now dead to you
if you open your mouth in this unit I
will break your face
I said yes sir I broke the rules
so he turned to his officers and he said
30 seconds and they beat me with Oak
sticks for 30 seconds then I was drugged
into the unit and thrown into my first
cell cell number 447.
the nurse then came up to me and by
wrote asked me if I could understand how
to fill out a dc-136 medical form should
I need to see a member of the staff for
any medical issues
wow so that's your first experience it
was my first day on death row
hey this is Ben Paul Jones we're just
taking a brief break so I can tell you
about one of our sponsors a brand new
six-part podcast from message heard and
podimo who robs the banks he follows
journalist Jake Warren as he sets out to
explore the Stranger Than Fiction tale
of the man who kidnapped a Banksy statue
from the middle of Central London in
broad daylight and held it to Ransom the
ACT would lead to an almost 20-year war
of bad blood relations and legal battles
that have still been waged today and it
all comes down to one man and one
Vendetta but it doesn't end there the
story will take us on a journey through
UK's most subversive subcultures from
art heists and art terrorists to 80s
football hooliganism and the 90s illegal
Rave scene even fetish parties and
throughout it all Jake will be trying to
get a hold of the most Elusive and famed
Anonymous artists in the world in the
new six-part series host Jake Warren
speaks to Tiger King of the art scene
Andy link and those closest to Banksy
himself exposing their two decade-long
Feud and attempting to track down the
world's most elusive Anonymous artist
who robs a Banksy is available now
wherever you get podcasts to hear the
whole series ad free subscribe to
Pottermore UK on Apple podcasts now back
to our episode
and what are you when you're looking
around are there can you describe death
row to us as other other prisoners
around you can you see other prisoners
can you communicate with other prisoners
I know you've been told that you're not
allowed to speak to them but what does
it look like from your cell
I was put in a 6 by 10 foot cell
and
I didn't get to see anyone for weeks
because
I was too terrified to come out of my
cell and find out about the next beating
stage
the next time I came out I was stripped
naked and taken to the shower six at a
time with 12 officers escorting two on
one two on one then they put you in this
giant building room and they turn on
these spigots of water above your head
you have three minutes to shower
do you get water on your body you get
soap on your body as best you can and
hope nobody attacks you and was that
something that was possible did people
attack each other in the showers of
course that was the most dangerous room
in the jail man for what reason
because you can get to somebody I
watched the kid get stabbed to death
with a pork chop bone that was sharpened
for is this because of arguments between
people or was it just on was it just
violence for the sake of violence
often ask myself it just seemed like
hate was all around me so intense it
didn't take much for people to kill
themselves or kill someone else my first
week there I saw someone kill themselves
it was horrible
but
occasionally a man couldn't take it no
more he would just jump off the top tier
and kill himself with handcuffs on
well just over the balcony and falling
all the way down to the floor at the
bottom yep head first wow and you saw
that in your first week yeah I thought
it was a mattress being thrown away
from them plastic mattress we were
forced to sleep on it hit the ground so
hard
I thought it was a plastic mattress so I
stood up and I looked out of my cell
window and there was a young black kid
could have been more than two years
older than me laying there twitching on
the ground oh God I mean I must have had
a huge effect on you at your age looking
down on that you know what was it like
mentally to know that there's no hope of
release anymore
I was so angry at the beginning I used
to beat my head on the wall
felt like if I stayed angry
I could fight
it was the stupidest thing in the world
you can't last with anger
but I was afraid and I didn't know what
else to do so I just constantly beat my
head against the wall all day long till
my head bleed
and then the officer took me out of this
home
and he went past one of the cells in
which the man killed himself and he made
me go in the song take some books out of
there that weren't urine stained or
damaged from blood and stuff
so I picked through this pile of books
and a man's cell that had already killed
himself
I took the books back to myself
I began my whole education that way why
did the officer do that just to give you
some books I think he took Mark pity on
me yeah
I was only a kid I was the second
youngest person in Pennsylvania's
history to be sentenced to die at that
time
and how many people were on death row at
the point you were there when I first
went there there was only 27 men right
in less than five years there was 245.
wow was that because they were ramping
up the amount of sentences given for the
crack epidemic sent America crazy
President Reagan got shot by a mentally
ill person by the name of John W
Hinckley
the United States government emptied out
its mental institutions right at the
epicenter of the crap epidemic and
everyone watched as America went from
one million incarcerated human beings to
3 million
hmm
and with the other people on death row
were did you ever communicate with them
like were you ever to were you able to
speak with them and then with you or was
it just were you just completely
yourself alone in yourself
I could talk to someone in the exercise
cages outside
I was given initially 15 minutes of
exercise every other day
so they would let you out of your cell
and you would run around in this
Courtyard as much as you were able to
for 15 minutes
or as long as the officer could take to
smoke two cigarettes and then they put
you back in yourself
occasionally they would let another
prisoner out with you so that the two of
you could run together
then they changed that up and built
these cages exercise cages 10 foot wide
and 20 foot long
and they used to stick you in there
so I would be locked up 23 hours a day
for 8057 days
so what what did you do every day what
did you do in your cell initially I had
to learn to fight for myself because my
lawyer didn't believe in me and he
mocked me
my first appellate attorney told me
he knew I was crazy and guilty but he
was going to follow my appeal anyway how
to pity
and is this a state appointed attorney
yeah so obviously it doesn't give you
much hope and how did that go that
appeal
I was actually granted a new a new
hearing for a new trial but
this is crazy
that's how I ended up escaping from
Death Row
I was being transported to court for
that new hearing
see I was convicted of the abduction and
and kidnapping of a woman in the state
of Delaware not in the state of
Pennsylvania and yet those factors were
used as aggravating factors to send me
to death row which is illegal so it
nothing else I had to have a new trial
and a new hearing
I'm on my way to court in February 15
1985. so how sorry to interrupt you so
how long at this point when you're being
given a new trial how long have you been
in death row at this point
three and a half years right so a long
time three and a half years and now
you're being transferred to a new place
for a retrial yes sir okay
I was arrested in 1981 in 1985 I was
being taken to court
we stopped to use the restroom in the
coldest night of the year and I'm
wearing eyeglasses I get out of the car
my eyeglasses fog up as I run into a
cubicle about 100 yards from the car
where it's parked
I go into the cubicle and I'm urinating
and my eyeglasses fog up again because
I'm breathing anyone that wears
eyeglasses can appreciate what happens
next
as I'm exiting the building to go back
to the patrol car to go to court
officers standing there holding the door
from me had to go to the toilet so bad
he let me go back by myself
as I'm jogging in the snow in the dark
back to the officer with fogged up
eyeglasses I don't see his reaction
he only turned around after smoking a
cigarette and saw me running at him he
pulls his gun out and all I see is his
arm come forward and he blasts a shot at
me why he thought I overpowered his
partner oh his partner should have never
left me alone after standing by the door
he didn't communicate to his partner
Nick's coming back by himself he went in
the toilet oh my God and because of this
one incident the officer starts shooting
at me thinking I overpowered his partner
tries to blow my head off I turn around
and run he fired another shot I hit the
ground I then jumped up and I ran in a
circle and I ended up hiding behind
their patrol car by about 50 yards
laying there watching them screaming at
each other about what had happened
I'm terrified I'm 24 years old I haven't
killed anybody now I've just been shot
at for escaping from Death Row I can't
trust them I can't trust anyone
I was laying there on my stomach
vomiting from the exertion and the shock
of all this happening when I took my
eyeglasses off I took the handcuffs off
my hands using my eyeglasses and then I
got up on my knees and I crawled behind
a police station I hid there
I didn't know what to do
so I stayed there for almost two hours
and then I was freezing so poorly I had
to get out of there
when I left that area someone saw me in
a helicopter began chasing me
so for five hours of my life I got
chased
so hard by a helicopter it was
unbelievable because the blades were
right down on me
at one point I was running towards this
10-foot fence and I didn't know what I
was going to do
but defense had been pushed back by the
snow plows who had been moving the snow
previous to that night and as I ran up
towards it just like magic I stumbled I
fell I hit my belly I slid and I went
under the fence and I slalomed down
about 60 yards down the embankment of a
train tracks
the helicopter had been right over my
head
the snow flying up over me as I fell and
slid down made him lose sight of me as I
slid and slave him down the hill I
landed perfectly I didn't even get cut
my face and everything was leading the
way I stood up like the abominables of
snowman shook off the snow and began
walking down the train tracks while the
helicopter circled back overhead
I walked for five miles to Fraser
Pennsylvania and I found the only car in
the in the parking lot was a 65 green
Mustang and I drove that to New York
City and got out of there oh my God
that's incredible so was the bowl to
lightning that hit the courthouse I'm
telling you this is crazy what's going
on with my life
So when you say you found a carve did
you hot wire it or were the keys in it
literally a 1965 Mustang had looked like
a coin slot for a cure I mean for the
key fob I literally turned it by hand
it was so old and so used I didn't need
keys to start it he just turned like the
cylinder by hand yeah and I put my foot
on the clutch started the car it was a
three-speed and I started driving away
my God
so at this point I mean you've escaped
but you weren't actually trying to
escape it almost sort of happened by
accident so what's going through your
head they're gonna kill me so you're not
thinking I need to hand myself in you
need you're thinking I need to get away
from it I'm thinking I got a new trial
being ordered for me by the Supreme
Court and they're afraid I'm going to
get to be able to prove my innocence
that are setting me up to kill me that's
my mindset
why would you blast at me say I didn't
know
what happened about the officers at the
time of the cubicle when I'm urinating
that was all testimony later on at my
Escape trial when they explained to the
court why they did what they did
this is all this is verified is crazy
so
I'm on the run
and now I have all these scratches all
over me
I'm in New York City and I look like a
horror show
I I saw all these televisions with my
mother on the on the news and I thought
they're going to kill me
it's crazy I saw in the window of a shop
it was two gay men standing there
together in a loving pose like
and it was a hair salon
and in an instant I don't even know why
I did it to this day I burst in the door
and I pretended I was being attacked by
my boyfriend and I said look you gotta
help me he's going to kill me look what
he's done to me they looked at me and
all these scratches and cuts and they
said sit down
in the next three hours these two men
put makeup on me they dyed my hair they
permed it and they got a friend of
theirs to come over who was an
optometrist and give me a pair of
eyeglasses
wow in three hours I walked out of that
shop completely unidentifiable to the
police
God so they did that just to help you
out they just do that with the goodness
of the heart some that they thought was
in trouble yeah it's amazing because I
was so young yeah they really did think
that my boyfriend was beating me and
hurting me and that I could Escape him
and his terrible clutches upon me if
they changed my appearance
so how long were you on the run for 25
days and then I turned myself in wow I
mean what's it like being on the Run oh
no Ben you don't ever want to know that
every moment you're just waiting to get
shot in the head um
I would be walking down the street and
freak out
do you know what I mean like
just
I had a crazy experience where I met a
girl in Florida
um we hooked up one night uh and then
she invited me back to her house to a
nice evening and I thought I was going
there to pick her up for a date
her mom invited me in and I ended up
having dinner in these people's house
with their family while being on Escape
it was it was so surreal
part of me wanted to be normal and I was
so polite and sweet at dinner when
police contacted that family and told
him later on who I was
her mother said well I can't believe
this is true about them because to this
date he's still the most polite kind
person my daughter ever brought home
crazy and what were you sleeping rough
at that point I had stolen that um a
man's coat and I took some uh
jewelry and stuff from his home I flew
to his house from New York City thinking
he would still be there so I I stole
from him
and I had enough money to get hotel
rooms so I was bouncing from hotel to
hotel trying to get a birth certificate
to get a passport to lead the country
so
I drove all over the State of Florida
back and forth trying to do this before
I realized it was just total Folly and I
had to go back okay so you just you
decided to go back because there was no
hope essentially it was there was no way
out did you is that what you thought I
knew I wasn't as clever as I thought I
was and I couldn't outwit the whole law
enforcement Society I had to go back
I called my father from Florida and I
asked him to tell the FBI where I was
so the state authorities in Penn and
Florida
arrested me put me on death row next to
Ted Bundy for eight months before they
sent me back home
wow
so did you meet head Bundy yeah he spit
on me he's why did he do that he tried
to sell me hope and I told him I don't
get off from killing little children and
thinking about my bad mommy and he can
go [__] himself
wow
he tried to sell you hope in what sense
he was a well-known jailhouse lawyer
right he signed me up for the law
library with him
Teddy knew about me from being
introduced to jail and he used to live
in Philadelphia so he was going to meet
me and was he famous at that point did
you know who he was I knew he was and I
had no respect for him yeah seeing the
misnomer is death row prisoners
get along with serial killers
people who go out and butcher women and
children do not get a warm reception in
prison um
Plus at the fact
at that time he was boasting about
getting one of his visitors pregnant so
he had gotten all the death row
prisoners visitation taken off them
everybody wanted to kill him right okay
okay so you could put there for eight
months did you say
and that was while they waited to move
you back to Pennsylvania to Pennsylvania
and this Escape had happened because you
were going for a retrial so was the
retrial then canceled or did that go
through what happened what was the
results there I ruined all my Appeals
the State of Florida put 35 years on to
my sentence
and at the time that I was returned to
Pennsylvania in 1986
I had
105 years of total sentences plus the
death penalty and I wasn't expect to
live
wow okay and at this point so earlier
you said that you were legally allowed a
retrial because basically because they
tried you in the wrong place was that
still possible I was at now just off the
table everything was off the table okay
right okay that must have been
quite hard to think about in the sense
that there was now there was no way out
right no I enrolled in University and I
began reading all the world's religions
why did you do that I don't know I
wanted to have respect for everyone's
beliefs
and the crazy thing is
over the next couple years while I read
all of the world's religions when I
finally got to the last one of reading
Sanskrit
I found out about DNA testing a
newspaper was about to be thrown away by
my next-door neighbor who was convicted
of multiple rapes and on the front
section of the text section was about
Sir Alec Jeffries at that time he was
just Dr Alec Jeffries from
leicestershire University and he had
taken the blood samples of men from
Lester and identified Colin Pitchfork as
the murderer of a woman in
leicestershire for the first time in
history science was used to identify
someone genetically
when I read that newspaper I knew one
thing I was innocent and I could prove
it
that must have been
a big moment for you to read that
because prior to that presumably all
evidence had to be based on things
people were willing to say they'd seen
or heard or you know things that were
caught on camera Maybe
whereas now there was a way of proving
definitively that something had happened
or somebody was somewhere that must have
been huge for you
unfortunately unfortunately for me
the real killer had B positive blood
typing
all we had in the early 80s was serology
of blood typing to tell that you were
part of a group and therefore possible
as a killer
you get it
fifteen percent of the white male
population be positive
when I found out about DNA
I knew it wasn't just a numbers game
this was identifiable
so I became the very first man in
America
to seek DNA testing in February of 1988.
1988 okay so you've gone back to death
row presumably how were the gods
treating it treating you when you went
back after the escape and everything
like that was it the same or were they
worse or did you know how is that
because I'm the reason I'm asking is
you're leading up to now
appealing again and I'm wondering how
that impacted on their view of you in
their treatment of you on my first year
back from Escape they used to strap me
up with 50 000 volts of electricity if I
wanted to come out of my cell
what do you mean they put a belly band
on me with a high intensity shocker
over both kidneys
and if I went out of my cell because I
had escaped and embarrassed them
I had to wear this belt called a stun
belt
and I had to watch while I exercised
wearing this as the two officers played
catch with it
as a just as a mind game thing
wow
wow the thought of people being in
control of you know your life and the
pain and suffering like that who had
little respect for you that must have
been horrendous
you're able to taught me love
being tortured actually taught me how to
have compassion for my attacker it
taught me how to love other human beings
how does that work
when you're faced with evil you have two
choices join in or use love
the only way you can hold on from being
tortured is to figure out your own value
system
do you value your own life do you value
Who You Are
if so you won't be hateful
it's interesting you say that because
earlier you said when you would I asked
you what feelings you're feeling you
said anger a lot of anger when you were
in death row and then just before you
said you started reading about religions
because you wanted to respect
everybody's opinions so there'd
obviously been some sort of transition
somewhere along the way from anger to
what you're describing now was there a
catalyst for that or was it just
something that began to happen
I got tired of being inhuman
I wanted to find out if God could truly
be real
why would you strike the courthouse
would a bowl to lightning on the day
that they found me guilty if you weren't
real I kept asking
I found out this crazy thing
I have a unique ability to love
for my torture love for the inmate who
tried to cut my throat
love for the people who hated me
and if I could hold on to my love I
could hold on to my Humanity
that's all it meant to me
and was that something you taught
yourself do you think anybody has that
or do you think it's something that was
just
within you everyone's born that way Ben
no one wants to be evil someone else has
driven them to their anger to be that
we're all born good
we learn hatred and anger from others
I didn't like that about myself
and I was so embarrassed that I couldn't
speak
that I made up my mind
the whole reason I began to develop the
ability to speak beautifully wasn't so
that I could get out of jail and talk to
anyone
I had two and a half minutes to speak
about my life before they executed Me by
strapping me into an electric chair and
pulling the switch
hmm so that's what they give you on
death row they give you two and a half
minutes to say something is that what
you're saying and that's my moment
I didn't want to be embarrassed anymore
[Music]
I thought okay I ruined my Appeals
I've screwed up they're gonna kill me
the only hope I have
I want to learn
how to overcome my speech impediment I
want to learn how to articulate words so
powerful and beautiful
that when they take my life for
something I didn't do the last thing I
hear is the beautiful voice of me
telling them how much I love them and
forgive them for what they did to me
wow
it's amazing it's what made me to find a
speaker in the world
I learned that every day of Our Lives is
a deaf speech if you think about it
each one of us are living under a death
sentence we don't know when it will come
very rarely you'll know the end
so every day of your life your duty is
to not only tell others who you are In
fairness and eloquence
but maybe just maybe you'll be the last
voice that they hear that day
don't you want it to be beautiful
this has been pal Jones so we're just
going to take a break from today's
episode to talk about one of our
sponsors better help this show is
brought to you by better help
how much time do you spend on yourself
in an average week
so easy to get caught up in what
everyone else needs from you and never
take a moment to think about what you
need from yourself but when we spend all
of our time giving it can leave us
feeling stretched thin and burned out
therapy can give you the tools to find
more balance in your life so you can
keep supporting others without leaving
yourself behind
therapy is something I've used several
times in my own life I think sometimes
we think it has to be for huge events or
massive changes but I like to just use
it every couple of months or a couple of
times a year check in on myself if
anything's feeling like a struggle book
a few sessions top myself back up
visit betterhelp.com minutes with today
to get 10 off your first month that's
better help
h-e-l-p.com slash minutes with
now back to the episode
I want to go back a little bit when you
were talking just then you were talking
about the people that you found a way to
love one of them you said was the person
the inmate you tried to Slit your throat
where did that come from I had a bounty
on me in prison
back in the 80s if you killed someone
who had a high profile case
people would put money on your books
and who would who would do that who
would pay the bounty
friends and family of the victims oh I
see right and they'd communicate that to
people in prison who thinks it's known
wow okay and and that's what happened
somebody tried to oh I had a lot of
attacks wow I've had multiple attacks
stage so that the first attack was the
fake out and then the other attack
happened in the hospital waiting for me
I've been stabbed so deeply
with a bed slat a metal bed slat that I
had to go ahead and hit head butt my
attacker over and over while holding the
knife inside of my belly
if you let it out they're gonna hit you
again and again with it
so I literally grabbed his arm held it
inside of my stomach while I head butted
him over and over
and that being a possibility of daily
life must have taken a huge toll
I changed the game
I wasn't going to be that way anymore
Ben as I said before you they put me in
the cage to fight against other men that
I didn't have any angst against and I
had to beat them to a pulp I've heard
you say this before and it's the most
unbelievable account of something that
just sounds so inhumane can you tell us
about that gladiator yeah
there were so many white officers beaten
on black inmates that after the crack
epidemic when they hired large numbers
of black officers to come up into the
mountains to work there
they couldn't tolerate this
so in a crazy scheme they came up with
gladiator school to level the playing
field
two black officers would come out pick
up a white guy March him out to the unit
put him in the cage and wait for two
white officers to go pick out a black
guy
and then they would bet on us
or laugh at us and tell us
and they'd just say to you you have to
fight
I beat a boy named Billy Tilly so bad I
broke his hip
it still bothers me
and Billy were friends
and what would happen if you refused
both of you get beat with the sticks
is this something that's ever been
like officially like prosecuted or
prosecuted yeah I mean it just sounds
horrendous it's not horrendous is real
it's what they did to us so they'd get
two guys put them in a cage and say
right fight each other till we tell you
to stop otherwise we're going to come in
there and be your paperwork's already
filled out if you refuse you're going to
go out in a body bag
and when would they let the the fight
stop what was the point somebody's got
to go down yeah
I stomped a lot of people I had a fight
with one guy I was so big I thought I
was going to get overwhelmed luckily I
broke his ankle and did him but
I promised my mother was coming home so
I don't care who they putting me in a
cage with I was gonna whoop his ass
and how many of those Gladiator sessions
do you think you went through until
probably about 50 God
and did you do you think they had a do
you think they'd have been worried that
it could have gone too far like surely
if someone had been actually killed that
would have been something that was
looked into or no
come on I know it's crazy for the
average world but you have to understand
this is what happened and caused the
Princeton experiment this is real
when people in power have an abusive
ability to hurt others
they choose that
and
yeah I had to learn all these Mist
martial arts
and probably one of the most dangerous
persons sitting before you and I can
kill you as you sit there or badly badly
maim you if I needed to hmm
I don't like that side that they
developed for me but I had to I had no
choice
they would put me in there against men
who butchered someone and ground them up
in the meatballs and fed them to her
parents
they were put me in the cage against
people who put people into a pit and
tortured them and tortured them and
torture them they were put me in the
cage against Monsters
horrendous
and
would you would I mean I know what you
can answer here but would there be no
sense of pleading with the guards or
appealing to their Humanity or anything
like that
no you make a joke try not to get hit
with the stick go handle your business
um
I had
I didn't kill anyone Ben
but I was around murderers
um
I had to be harder than the murderers
and you were there on death row and you
were innocent and there was other people
on death row do you think there were in
a similar position to you or was your
impression of that that death row was by
and large filled with very dangerous
people who were there for the correct
reason
85 percent obviously guilty no problem
with that I agree to that but I got
other people off the death row who were
innocent both while I was on death row
and after I got out
okay so that's a good place to go back
to the story that you just arrived at
you read the article about Colin
Pitchfork and that showed you a new
method of proving your innocence when
everything else had solved run drying
gone away how did you progress that
I've told my lawyer initially I wanted
to try for DNA testing and he was
excited about this because it could
prove either way if I did it or not
so my very first phone call with him it
was upbeat
a weekend later
we're at the end of the conclusion of a
weekend I was put back on the phone with
him
and that's when he told me all the
evidence from my homicide trial was
destroyed and gone there would be no DNA
testing
what
what when they found out that I was the
first guy in America to ask for DNA
testing they tried for the next 15 years
to Murder Me by destroying all the
evidence
what was the official reason given for
the evidence being destroyed
I never got that I kept finding out that
the detective would take some evidence
and put it in his desk drawer and leave
it there for three years and the court
wouldn't answer me
when they found the Killer's gloves and
more of evidence of the woman's
underwear in her clothing again
no answering and they drug it out for 15
years while I was then stricken with
Hepatitis C so the woman I married and
was in love with for nine years of this
ordeal when I first found out about DNA
testing I had the courage to tell her I
was innocent and I married her in
handcuffs
and then over nine years she stood by me
and helped me with this effort for DNA
testing and then she left me when the
evidence broke open and Spilled in
transit
so after 15 years of trying for DNA
evidence and being stricken with an
illness I asked to be executed
okay there's a lot there let me just go
back a little bit
um
so you met somebody in prison and got
married to them yes uh was that uh can
you explain a little bit about that the
Pennsylvania prison Society was a group
that was trying to have Huntington
prison shut down for its active
practices of torture
they came there one day to interview
five different prisoners on death row
and get their stories before a court
about the complaints that they had about
the
torture that they were enduring
when I was brought out having already
escaped from death row and ruining my
Appeals
I wasn't like all the other prisoners
before me I had no laments so I sat
before this woman named Jackie and her
friend Pamela and I told him I had no
complaints
and they were like but they're torturing
men around you and you're being made to
fight and like all these horrible things
and I said yeah
and for the love of God I'd love a good
cup of coffee
and they were like how could you be so
Cavalier about this this woman was
really put off by the fact that I wasn't
complaining but I was sitting there with
105 years plus the death penalty I was
going to die because I made up a story
about a murder I didn't know anything
about I put myself on death row with my
own stupid mouth get it
I didn't have any complaints
I felt like I deserved a lot of the
punishment they were giving to me
but it bothered her and so she came back
by herself the next week and the next
week and the next week
and she wouldn't hear no she wanted to
know why I wouldn't bother to be upset
about where I was and I told her
I'm in the process of living
I'm not in the process of being here or
being here to be executed I'm trying to
live as such I was in the midst I told
her reading all the world's religions
and as many beautiful books as I can so
that by God I'll have enough Poise to
speak for myself when they execute me
six months after I met her I found out
about DNA testing
it was like a miracle God gave me
someone to love me while I fought for
myself
I didn't know she would leave me
and you said she would leave you after
the evidence broke open in transit what
was that I finally got the federal court
to help me and provide funding for DNA
testing
and when the evidence was shipped out to
California from Pennsylvania it broke
open in transit and we lost all that
evidence in the Box
Jackie after nine years of being married
to me and loving me
walked into the prison and said I can't
take it no more I have to get out of
this situation because my mother just
died and I'm in a house full of legal
boxes and you're never coming home
so I manned up I wrote her a beautiful
letter and I thanked her for the nine
years that she loved me and I sent her
on her way
you still in touch no
wow
and that that must have been crushing
for you the the evidence being destroyed
yeah so I decided right then and there I
was going to circumnavigate the globe
while sitting in my cell and death row
I began writing to pen pals all over the
world and I asked him only one favor
set my hair free into the oceans because
that's my DNA and I might not make it
out here so
could you do me a favor and let me be
free
so I sent my hair to New Zealand Peru
Australia
Europe everywhere I could find a pen pal
and I asked him could you do me a favor
help me circumnavigate the globe while
I'm sitting on death row
and then how how did you
how long did you the point that the
evidence broke open where you you
thought you'd found an answer to your
innocence how long had that been how
long have you been on death row at that
point
18 years wow okay 18 years so what were
the events that led up to
your release
I was stricken with hepatitis C yeah how
do you get Hepatitis C the dentist
didn't change their suction return on
his
um machinery
and after the Escape they beat me for
four minutes with clubs and they broke
my teeth so he had to do oral surgery to
cut my gums and removed bones
so
I got stricken with the same hepatitis C
that killed a couple of the other men
underneath me wow so I had to sit my
cell and listen to them torture the
other inmates that died
okay so you you've got this illness I
mean one of the things I wanted to ask
is you know you you'd been sitting on
death row now for around 20 years you
know for this country as you know
doesn't have the death penalty why don't
they when they've decided to give the
death penalty and and that you're guilty
of it why don't they execute you the
next week what's the 20th you have an
automatic guaranteed appeal
so when there's 250 appeals going on it
takes a long time for the courts to
address all of them ice as well as the
non-deaf penalty cases I say so the the
the time it takes to execute a prisoner
is basically the time it takes for them
to exhaust the appeal process while
amongst the backdrop of a thousand
appeals okay okay
all right so so you you were yes you
were ill you had hepatitis and yeah
please take us forward from there
signed up for the treatments interferon
and Rib of Iran are the two
cancer-fighting drugs because in the
Western World the philosophy is nearly
killed the host and you'll kill a virus
within the host so they nearly killed me
but they Blinded Me in My Song and I
felt like that was enough
so when I got my eyesight back after
three days of being blinded in my soul I
sat down and wrote a letter to the
courts and I asked to be executed for
something I didn't do and why did you
was that just the end of your that was
just the end of what you could take
I decided not to be like Dale Carter who
was tortured on his way out of dying
from the same illness in the cells
underneath me with the nurses
euphemistically asking him would he like
some aspirin while he died of the pain
of impacted bowel syndrome
God I wasn't going out like that
so you requested an earlier execution I
asked that my lawyers be dismissed so
that I could be executed and the federal
court stepped in and finally ordered the
remaining DNA testing be done based on
you asking to be executed why would they
do that because a man that's been ex
asking for DNA for 15 years didn't sit
right with the judge okay
so that sounds like someone doing the
right thing after a lot of people doing
the wrong thing yes sir
okay
and
what happened in February of 2003
the murderer's gloves yield the DNA from
the victim and from the murderer and
from a possible second female victim
the court then ordered a consumptive
test of the remaining evidence I was
brought to this cheap hearing and agreed
to it like I wouldn't
and in July of 2003 they got spermatozoa
results from the victim's underwear
matching to Killer's gloves of who
unmale unknown male whoever he is and
then another's man's DNA as well and
none of it matched me
wow and was that at that moment is that
you being free exonerated being
exonerated but it still took me another
eight months to be let go okay so
they've decided that you definitely are
innocent why does it take eight months
to be released no one wants to let the
murderer or the monster go that they
feared who escaped and terrorized them
[Music]
they literally thought I was going to
get out and get a gun and come kill them
because what they did to me um
was it my mindset but that was theirs
what did it feel like to be told the DNA
test had come back include you it was
very um
it was the most anti-climactic moment of
my life wow okay why
I had my first lawyer on the phone
telling me the results
segue into how I was the office joke
how they didn't believe me and
oh my God I guess you are innocent
followed by me hanging up the phone from
him calling my mother up and trying
excitedly tell her to news only to be
told
that's wonderful but your brother
Mikey's having a seizure at my feet and
I can't even handle that right now I'm
so happy you're going to get your life
back Nikki but Mikey's laying on the
ground here and I gotta put something in
his mouth so he doesn't choke to death
wow okay
it's pretty heavy
well how did you feel
cried my eyes out um
look at the damage I did to my family
look at the damage I did to my life the
damage you did to your family oh yeah
I put myself on death row by being a
junky thief and a liar
I put myself on death row they just
helped to put me there as well
I never once want anybody to think I'm
not responsible for what I did to myself
I made up a lie about this poor victim
may I never forget that
and I cried because I ruined my life not
because they did anything to me
I let my parents suffer my little
brother died of a drug overdose in my
basement
I'd never be proud about that
[Music]
um
okay so what's so it takes eight months
well what's what what what's the time
leading up to your release what does
that look like do they tell you there's
a date you're going to be released on or
you know there's a conversation ongoing
I swear to God then they botched my
release man okay eight o'clock in the
morning they put me in a van with all my
little letters and stuff
I say goodbye to the administration
it's my moment they drive me across this
big prison called Greene County supermax
we get up to the first gate
oh man I can see my parents they're
outside with the Press
literally 50 yards away from me
and get up to the last gate and they say
you ain't going home paperwork in
Florida is not done
so they actually had the prison officer
so incensed by this he refused to turn
the vehicle around he backed the vehicle
up across the whole compound of the
prison
he said I'm not turning around
so we backed up and the administration
surrounded the van and started pleading
with me to understand that it wasn't
them playing a game on me or a joke on
me
that this was just a procedural problem
for the State of Florida and that right
at that moment a lawyer named Elliot
sherker had put a lawyer on a on a
flight to Tallahassee Florida to State
Capitol to try and get my paperwork
right at that moment stamped and
completed so I could be released
and how long did that take then that
probably hours so he was sitting in the
vampires I was sitting in a building not
in a Cell because they they asked me
what could they do for me I said look I
just spent 8057 days on death row were
in his cell whatever you do don't put me
back in the cell because I can't promise
not to hurt you
okay so talk us through being actually
when it all gets stumped and it all gets
done what does release feel like after
all this time
I walked up to the microphones out front
they didn't put me back in a van they
walked me out the front doors
I walked up to the assembled press and I
told him about my two friends that were
innocent in the prison behind me and I
walked off I didn't complain I didn't
lament I had no time for this
I knew what I was going to do Ben
I was going to be next level me
and What's Next Level you
I was going to make all of this mean
something
I wasn't going to let what they did to
me mean nothing
[Music]
so right there on the spot I decided to
use my education
I started an economic embargo against
Pennsylvania by going to five of its
biggest trade Partners in Europe and
here in the United Kingdom
this is what led me to become a UK
citizen
I came here to address a combined
session of the lower house of parliament
only 10 months after that day when I got
released
imagine you have this wonderful
world-class education where you know you
can effectuate change and you've been
given a beautiful voice practicing for
your own death I knew I could do this
so much so
that I went on in just months after my
release to have some of the biggest
platforms ever of speaking including the
Coliseum in Rome and other places
and did you did the US ever admit
wrongdoing did you receive any
compensation I had the file a lawsuit
against Pennsylvania but no one's going
to ever bear a responsibility like that
and come forward and apologize you're
never going to get resolution and any
money that they're going to give you is
going to be pity money of course yeah so
I decided when I first came here I went
to Hyde Park Speakers Corner and I began
practice my speaking that's where it all
began I had no bank account no home
other than the one that was being given
to me by the woman I had met who brought
me here
and I began my whole career believing in
myself by standing in the park
practicing my speaking beautifully
and you've mentioned God a lot during
this conversation are you quite a
religious person I am not but I'm a
spiritual person you know the difference
please tell me religiosity is adherence
to the religion whereas I believe in God
itself
and its energy form is in many forms
that's why I made the Endeavor to read
all of the world's religions so I could
respect you if you're Hindu Muslim or
whatever
I believe that God is good
that if you read any one of the world's
religions invariably it's an instruction
course of being a good human
for the reward might be in the afterlife
or this life but still it's still an
instruction on what being good
your life has been incredible so unique
when you look back on it what do you
think it's taught you
upon looking back and reflecting upon
everything the answer truly is low
if you can develop kindness and I mean
real kindness for yourself and others
you can become the most incredibly
strong human being you ever imagined
about yourself
I used to think that anger was the way
to keep me alive and that my fist and my
Fury were my way of answering any
challenge
then I found out how powerful I could
become by being a kind person kind
enough to myself to respect me kind
enough to in life to help others
that's such an empowering thing I know
I'm one of the baddest men on the planet
I am the finest speaker alive and I
believe in myself so much because I
learned to love this person that I am
I wrote a book called the kindness
approach
and basically I have lightning in a
bottle I can get that person whoever it
is
to actually come back
time and again people with destroyed
lives have trusted me and they've healed
if I think about that
isn't there any bigger more beautiful
gift you can be given than that alone
I'm living one of the greatest stories
of all time I get that
but I'm also living it with kindness
look I mean earlier on in the in the
conversation you said that you wanted to
become a great speaker and it's actually
really hard to imagine you not being a
great speaker because genuinely I've sat
here for the last hour and a half just
absolutely entranced by not only your
story but your unbelievable way of
telling it you're a fantastic speaker
and I just want to say thank you so much
for coming here and being so open and
sharing such an incredible story
thank you Ben
I want you to know something
every time I speak I have this one
notion
there's a person who's going to hear
this who's had the most tragic things
but listening to me they know it's all
lie and they're going to come to me
I'll show you by message you'll see
I've had so many incidents like this
my blessing will come from the person
who needs this moment to be real
for that I'll always pour my heart out
over and over because I know that's my
purpose now
I can't believe I got a chance to sit
down and address so many people in the
blad Bible platform
for those of you who don't know this
I came back to England recently because
I'm in love with this country
so I don't care if you're from Scotland
Wales Ireland or wherever
thank you for being family to me I thank
you for listening to me today because we
only get this one chance
may it be beautiful may it be something
important for you
foreign
thanks so much for being here it was a
pleasure to meet you
in the same Ben thank you everyone and I
look forward to you finding me on
Instagram or wherever and I hope that I
can come back in the future and show
that this is real of course I look
forward to it definitely
thank you brother
even though it was quite comfortable
there I was going to get executed they
said they were going to make an example
of a Westerner and I think I was it
there's a time limit there yeah I had to
go out the old-fashioned way
which was
um cut my way out of the cell bars